字幕: Akiko Kamio
校正: Kazunori Akashi
(拍手)
皆さんこんにちは
宮城県から参りました 早坂久美子です
現在 36歳です
高校まで宮城で過ごして
大学から北海道に渡ってきました
ちょうど半々の人生です
私は物凄く緊張しやすいので
地元の母さんが 心配だからと
お守りをくれたんです
これが まず手作りの物なんですけれども
スペインタイルで作ったペンダント
そしてもう一つは Tシャツを切って
編み込んで作ったミニミニ草履
ボタンみたいで可愛いでしょ？
さて 今日は
『９割 破壊された街が楽しいと思える理由』
という話をしたいと思います
『９割が破壊された街』 それってどこ？
と思われると思うんです
これは丁度 赤く示していますが
宮城県の女川町 今私が住んでいる町です
仙台よりも北にあって
石巻の隣にある小さな町です
2011年3月に発生した東日本大震災では
震源地から一番近い町 そして
人口の１割が亡くなったり
行方不明 [になったり]
そして建物の89.2%
およそ９割が破壊された町です
そして現在人口は
１万人を超えていたものが
７千人をきりました
被災３県の中で何かとワースト１
という事が多い町でもあります
今ここで私は被災地と北海道を
繋げる活動をやっています
そうすると「故郷だから頑張ってるんだね」
と勘違いされます
私は子供の頃に１回しか
行ったことがない町なので
行った時も未知の世界でした
なぜその女川町を選んだのか
それは ある言葉との出会いからでした
「何も無くなったから 何でも出来るね」
「何しようかね」
この言葉がとても魔法のように
聞こえたんです
これは地元の小学生から
80のお爺ちゃんお婆ちゃんまでが
合言葉のようにして
口ずさむ言葉なんです
ここの町を元に戻すのではなくて
生まれ変わるんだ
私にはそう見えました
ここの町には何かがある 面白い
入ってみたいとそう思いました
そしてもう一つ
支援をスムーズにする為には
間に立つ人間が必要だと感じたからです
私が被災地に入ったのは
悪臭と害虫を駆除する為の作業です
女川に入る前日でした
別の町での出来事です
害虫駆除はとても需要が高かったので
役所とタッグを組んで行う予定だったのです
それが連絡のミスマッチで
何も用意されていない
おまけに職員の方は
開き直ってしまう
あまりにも心ない言葉に
私は折れそうになりました
でも その時にちょっと思ったんです
「あれ これって私達だけがこんな対応
受けているはずないわよね」
「でもこのままじゃ
支援が無くなってしまう」
そう思うと同時に何かが
欠けているんだなと引っ掛かったんです
そして作業をしている中で
「何だろうな 」と
考えている中で気付いたのが
間に立つ人間 宮城と
北海道の間に立つ人間がいれば
小さな事も大きな問題にならなくて済む
支援の輪というのは広がっていく
はずだと感じたのです
そこで私が間に立つということで
初めて行ったのが
北海道で女川の商品を売ることでした
何でそんないきなりと思うと思うんですが
まずは女川の事を知ってもらいたいな
と思ったんです
「女川」と聞いて今でこそ
被災地だというイメージがありますけれども
「女」の「川」で
「女川（おながわ）」なんですけれども
北海道ではほとんどの方が
「めかわ って呼ぶんでしょ」又は
「めがわ って呼ぶんでしょ」
と言うんです
多分きっとこれは
「女満別（めまんべつ）町」の
「女（め）」という
イメージが強いからだと思います
そういう意識を変えたい
そして他の地域よりも北海道は
被災地への意識の低下が早かったです
被災者にとって何が一番怖いと言ったら
津波とか地震も もちろん怖いです
それ以上に怖いのが 自分達の存在を
忘れられてしまうという事なんです
あなた達はもういないのよ
あなた達にあった事は
私達は何も知らないの
「ふん」と見られるのが
一番怖くて悲しい事なんです
それを防ぐ為にどうしようかと[考えました]
だったら人間にとって
一番欠かせない食から伝えていこう
その時 女川町で復興していた
お土産というのは
サンマを練り込んで作った
かりんとうでした　とても斬新です
ですが これに賭けようと思いました
何故かと言うと震災前 女川町は
本州でも有数のサンマの水揚げを
誇る町だったんですね
だからサンマ[を選びました]
でも最初から上手くいった
訳ではありません
今でこそ本当に
「さあ お客さん寄って行って下さい」
（宮城県の方言）「女川のうめえもの
持って来たから食べてってけらいん」
って大声で言えるんです
多分このホールの奥にいる人にも
届く位 言えると思うんです
でもそれまで私は
販売とかやったことがないんです
もう 震えて震えて駄目でした
声が出なくて
「どうしよう マイク持参しようかしら」
でもそういう場所に
立つことさえも嫌でした
そいう時に折角呼んで頂いた
イベントでも もう逃げたいな
場違いだからどうしよう
そればっかり考えていました
でもある時
こんな対処方法を考えたんです
それは自分自身の頭の中に
もう一人の自分を作る事なんです
これは例えば「恥ずかしい
「どうしよう どうしよう どうしよう」
とぐずぐず言う自分
そして —
「折角のチャンスなのに何やってんの」
「恥ずかしいのと売れないのとどうなのよ」
「女川を知ってもらうチャンスでしょ」
という勝気な私との戦いなんです
それを頭の中で何度も繰り返すことで
穏やかになっていく
結果として女川にとってチャンスなんだから
恥ずかしいのは我慢して頑張る
と自分で思うんです
こういう事って
他の時にも使えて
例えば 自分にとって冷静さを失った時
それとどうしようと迷った時
そういう時にもう一人の
自分というのを [頭の中に] 作って
私はこれまで乗越えてきました
とても役立つんです 意外と
そしてその時に自分の立場が何であるか
本当は自分はどうしたいのか
という事も頭の中で復唱するんです
私の判断基準は女川の
為になるか ならないかという事
だからとても大胆になる時があるんです
いつもの自分だったら出来ない
「ちょっと ちょっと ちょっと」
という位 図々しくなる私もいます
それで失敗する事もあるんです
でも 女川の為と軸を決めているので
後から後悔する事はないです
さあ 次に行こうと
切り替わるんです
間に立って行うのは 色々[な事が]あります
企業間 例えば北海道の企業と
女川の企業を繋げて地場産品を広める
新商品を作る
そして地域の人々同士を繋げる
実は 私 早坂久美子という名前
同姓同名の方との出会いで
滝川と女川の出会いが繋がったんです
それが「紙袋ランターン」というものです
人生の中でなかなか無いな
と思う事なんですけれども
この「紙袋ランターン」というのは
紙袋に色々な模様を切り込んで[います]
本場の滝川では真冬に行われます
中に雪を入れてロウソクを灯して
楽しむもの
でも 女川ってほとんど雪が積もらないんです
だから 女川では
どうしようかなと思った時に
木片を重しにして ロウソク代わりに
ライトを灯して飾ったんです
すると「綺麗だね 私も作ってみたいわ」と
小さい子供達から80代後半のお婆さんまで
今は夢中になって
作家さんとして作っています
そうした交流を繋げるのも
間に立って繋げるという事だと思います
そして北海道では
その真冬だけのイベントが
女川では
１年中楽しめるものになりました
夜道の明かりが本当にないんです
だから子供達が 高校生が駅から帰ってくる
仮設住宅までの道のりに灯す
商店街に灯す
そして災害復興住宅に灯す
今では女川にとって
とても無くてはならい物となっています
そしてもう一つ
こちらを見て下さい　木の椅子です
これは北海道の東川町との
繋がりから出来た物です
「輝く望み」の椅子と書いて
「輝望（きぼう）の椅子」と呼びます
多分 ご存知[の方] 知っているよという方も
いらっしゃると思います
北海道では「君の椅子」プロジェクトとして
馴染みがあると思うんです
これがどうして女川に合ってきたか
「君の椅子」プロジェクトというのは
元々 東川町で子供が産まれた喜び等を
町全体で分かちあおうよ 子供の成長を
みんなで見守ろうよという事で生まれた物です
それは女川でも受け継ぎたいなと思っています
2006年に東川町で始まった
「君の椅子」プロジェクト
震災の当日 岩手 宮城 福島
３県では104人の子供達が産まれました
この子供達にも届けられています
こんな素敵な事を女川でもしたいね
そして東川の協力を得て
昨年の４月から女川町でも
プロジェクトとしてスタートしました
そして5月30日現在 32人女川で産まれた
新たな命の子達に届けられています
(拍手)
でも実はこれには
もう一つの顔があります
ある時 町の交流館で
お婆さんに会ったんです
「全然街並みが変わっちゃって
山も木もどんどん削られて
生きる為だって言われてもね
悲しいんだ」って
目に一杯涙を溜めて
私に話し掛けて来たんです
その時に私は
「実はね その杉の木」—
この [椅子は] 伐採された
杉の木から出来たものです —
だから「その杉の木はね
こういう風に 輝望の椅子として
生まれ変わっているんだよ」と伝えました
そうするとお婆さんの顔は
ぱあっと明るくなって
「良かった　近所に赤ちゃん
生まれたんだ 見に行かないとね」
笑顔で帰って行かれたんです
女川では元々思い出や 消えゆく風景を
形として残そうということで
この「輝望の椅子」が
伐採される杉の木で作られました
でも作ってみたら人々の心の支えに
一番なっている物の一つになりました
色々な事が 女川に入って４年
順風満帆であったと言う事は言えません
私は やっぱり外者なんです
だから地域の人と近くなれば近く成る程
嫌がられるんですね
でも逆に大切にされる事もあります
そのきっかけは 浜のお父ちゃんと
お母ちゃんとの出会いです
この人達の存在が
今の私を作ってくれています
夕方になると必ず
電話かメールがくるんです
「もしもし 早坂です」と言うと
「今日夕飯どこで食べるの」
「まだ決めてないんだけど仕事中だから」
「じゃあ 家で食べなさい」
また別の日になります
「はい もしもし 早坂です」
「今日どこでご飯食べるのさ」
「〇〇さん家で」
「明日は？」
「まだ 決まってないよ」
「じゃあ 家で食べなさい」
という事で私はほとんど夕食を一人で
家で食べたことがないんです
「きぼうのかね商店街」というのが
女川に復興商店街としてあります
そこに私よく行くんですね
時間も関係なくぷらぷらしてても
楽しい商店街なんです
歩いていると
「あんた 良いとこにいた タッパーに
おかず入れたから持ってかいん
— 持って行きなさい」
そして頂きます
するとこれが朝御飯になるんです
この浜のお父ちゃんと
お母ちゃんとの繋がりは
ただ何気ない会話の中で
今 何が女川で問題になっているか
ということを気づかされる
チャンスでもあります
そして私が次に何をしたいか
何が出来るかではなく
何がしたいかと言う事を考える
きっかけを与えてくれます
こういう独特な浜のお父ちゃんとお母ちゃん
との繋がり[を持つ事]は
なかなか難しいんですけれども
これは東北の独特の習慣を活かしています
それが「おぢゃっこ飲み」です
「おぢゃっこ飲み」と言うのは
「はい こんにちは」って入って行って
大概の家で 漬物、煮物、お菓子
と用意をしているので
お茶を飲みに行く 世間話をしに行く
暇な時は お爺ちゃん お婆ちゃん[達は]
１日で3、4件ふっと回ります
いつでも来ても良いように用意してあるんです
そういうような事を 私は女川にいて
何も知らないですから
情報収集の為 そして地域の風土を知る為に
避難所時代から行ってきました
すると１日でなんですけれども ７個も
シュークリームを頂いた事があるんですね
某コンビニで新製品
某お菓子屋さんで新製品
支援で頂いたから
あなたが来るっていうから取って置いたの
結構きつかったんです
お陰で女川に入って
14キロも増えました（笑）
戻らないんです
でもその母さん達との関係はとっても大事
そしてポイントは
その関係性を縮めるのには
５つのポイントがあるんです
まず笑顔で近づく事
何にも知らないから
教えてねと頼る事
共通点を見い出す事
そしてひたすら聞き役に回る事
最も重要なのが
たまに喧嘩をする事です
お客さんとは
絶対しない事ですよね
近くになるからこそ 「あんた腹立つ」
と言われても 怒られても
次の日には「昨日ごめんね」
と言って仲直りになるんです
浜の母さん達が
私を家族だと言ってくれる
そう言う事があるから
踏ん張れるんですね
たまに困る時もあるんです
浜の母さん達は私を娘って呼ぶ時が
あるんですよね
それも最近気づきました
それは悪い事ではないんですけれども
ただちょっと困るんです
他の人に私を紹介する時に
「うちの娘なの 面倒な子だけど何とか
育て上げました」とさらっと言うんですね
それを 他に支援に来た[方々が] —
東京から 福岡から
色んな支援の方が来て下さいます —
その時に疑問に思うんですよね
「何か至る所で早坂さんを
娘という人がいるんですけれども
本当のお母さんてどの人ですか？」
だから私きっぱり言うんですね
「私 北海道の人間なの
血の繋がりもなければ嫁でもないのよ」
と言うと皆さんに衝撃が
走るみたいなんですね
そういった方達を 家族を
守っていきたいと思ったら
この町がどんな状態にあっても
面白いと感じる事があると思います
『９割破壊された街が 楽しいと思える理由』
そのポイントは先ほども言いましたが
「何も無くなったから 何でもできるね 」
という発想
そしてそこには町民が
思っている 意識の転換
その宝と言うのが 発想の転換をする
そしてそれが実際に動き出している
というのが女川の強みであり
浜の父さん母さんが色んな方が来た時に
家族として対応できるものが
あるからだと思います
拙い話でしたが
ご静聴ありがとうございました
(拍手)